[Music]
now a fair warning to those who complain
that the subjects i cover on this show
are often too dark and disturbing
if you feel that way you're not gonna
like this segment
and i say that in order to give you time
to bail out now
if you want for those who remain here's
a headline that sounds like something
that a mentally ill babylon b
writer might come up with in the middle
of a lsd induced psychotic break
here's the headline trans youtuber chris
chan
39 is listed as female in police report
and will
will be jailed with women um despite
arrest for raping her dementia sufferer
mother
79. now unfortunately although there is
indeed plenty of mental illness involved
in this story it is not satire
an apparently well-known youtube
personality and web comic creator
was allegedly caught on tape admitting
to raping his own elderly mother
and because this monster now claims to
be a woman he is being housed with
actual women in a women's prison
the daily mail has more though i warn
you that the details are
extremely difficult to stomach here's
what it says
transgender youtuber chris chan 39 was
identified as female by
police will be housed with women despite
being biologically male after she was
arrested for raping her mother
the vlogger and artist who goes by
christine weston chandler was arrested
after leaked phone calls allegedly
revealed her admitting to raping her
mother 79
who suffers from dementia chandler's
biologically male but came out as
transgender
at the end of 2014. chandler's arrest
came just days after a phone call was
leaked on an instant messaging platform
on which a person believed to be
chandler seemingly admitted to having
sex with her elderly mother who was
believed to have dementia
during the eight minute conversation
chandler apparently tells a friend that
it was her mother barbara
who made the first move leading the two
to kiss according to audiophile
to the audio file which newsweek
reported as the call continues
the person said to be chandler says that
she and her mother now have a routine
where they have sex every third night
and that her mother enjoys it uh that's
as
far as i could possibly go there you'll
notice how the daily mail has taken
great care to ensure that they respect
the pronouns of this alleged rapist
newsweek yahoo news the new york post
every other media outlet that's reported
on the story
they've all done the same a man's
feelings must still be respected even
after he sexually assaults his own
mother
it would seem never mind the fact that
chris chan
is not only a deviant rapist allegedly
but also
clearly insane i pulled his most recent
youtube video before his arrest to give
you an idea
and not that you probably needed any
convincing about his dire mental state
but
uh here it is anyway watch listen here
and listen good i have told y'all i kept
it going
time and time again but y'all keep
putting it on put it on
but my little point generation five
is cancelled g4
friendship is magic needs it's five
more seasons it needs to go on to season
14.
now this is the last
straw because for the good and safety
of this timeline you need to get that
pulled off the shelves in an amazon
store so wherever else
oh i can stop it there um so you get the
idea
as best i can well you probably don't
get the idea at all as best as i can
tell he's yelling at hasbro about my
little pony
which is yet more confirmation from my
position that adults who watch cartoons
are weird
probably not this weird but weird and
yet somehow we're supposed to believe
that the self-identification of this
raving lunatic rapist
allegedly is a serious and meaningful
insight and not just another of his
deranged hallucinations
many people on the internet certainly
believe that which is why social media
in the aftermath of his arrest and the
reporting on the story
has have largely been more upset at the
people who misgender
chris chan than they are chris chan for
sexually violating his
elderly mother more importantly the
court system
takes this delusional predator seriously
to the point of housing him in a prison
with
actual women and by the way a large
portion of the women in any prison
are going to be sexual abuse survivors
and and now they're going to be locked
in a cell with a large unstable accused
rapist
this is certainly a violation of the
constitutional protections against cruel
and unusual punishment and it's even
more certainly a violation of basic
common sense and human decency
but here's what makes all this even more
disturbing
if it's possible for it to get more
disturbing
millions of americans those on the
ideological left
do not possess the moral or intellectual
framework to object
to most aspects of this story
they cannot object and do not object to
a male
sex predator being housed with women and
he is not the only male sex predator to
be housed with women
in women's prisons this is happening
across the country
and that's bad enough on its own but
they also
can't really object even to incest in
and of itself
now in this case the victim has dementia
which means that she cannot consent
which means everyone agrees that it's a
horrific crime and yet if it weren't for
the dementia
then the leftist worldview would say
that it is simply a choice that two
people who love each other have made
and it isn't hurting anyone and we have
no room to judge their lifestyle
it's true that most leftists are not at
the point where they're going to openly
defend consensual incest
but their world view leads to that
conclusion inevitably inescapably
everything they say about sexuality lays
the groundwork
they have no basis to object to incest
if it's consensual
and and they know it they have no basis
to object to any
sexual activity or lifestyle at all as
long as it passes the consent test
now this one doesn't and so they're
saved from having to defend the most
revolting aspect of this story
but they still have to and do defend the
rest of it
what do we make of that how do we go
forward as a country knowing
that that when half of us hear a story
about a man
who rapes his elderly mother and is sent
to a women's prison
we can only object to part of it and
even then the objection is qualified and
conditional
well i'm not sure that we do
go forward as a country ultimately the
chasm between us
is vast and deep and and cannot be
traversed
there is no middle ground or compromise
between the two sides
we can barely see each other across the
divide
and all we can hear is unintelligible
shouting
which is why all anyone does anymore is
shout
because we are so far apart
and that's why literally everyone
involved in this story
is of course i don't think i need to say
it
canceled but the good news
well i wish i could end on good news but
i'm not sure there is any good news we
could pull
from all of that you can go somewhere
else for your
your uh your portion of good news for
the day um what i can give out
with this story are cancellations and i
certainly hand them out
with uh with a vengeance listen
hit that subscribe button right now do
it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated